NARRATOR: Kevin
Dykstra and his team
have traveled once again to
Traverse City, Michigan where
they have scheduled an
important face to face
meeting with Marty Lagina.
Gentlemen, welcome.
Why don't we all have a seat?
NARRATOR: For Kevin
Dykstra, everything
he has spent the past seven
years researching and working
for now hangs in the balance.
Well, gentlemen,
I understand you're
going to show me some stuff
that brings me up to speed.
I know you've been just intense.
Oh, it's been busy.
Yeah.
I'm hoping for a special
presentation here, Kevin.
Well, I think you're
in store for one.
Good.
You wanted tangible proof.
This is what we have.
MARTY LAGINA: Comes the box.
[laughter]
This isn't a box.
This is a treasure chest.
That's what this is.
MARTY LAGINA: OK.
What have we got here?
Lot of cool stuff.
It's a lot of rusted parts,
but one of the most telling
things we found down in
Irwinville where Jefferson
Davis was captured, we
actually found the wagon parts
we went down there to look for.
It's a bolt.
Threaded bolt?
Threaded bolt.
GARY DRAYTON: I think what
we're seeing is the iron
remnants of six burnt wagons.
Yeah.
KEVIN DYKSTRA: It sure
looks like it to me.
As we uncovered the
wagon parts, we then
uncovered this coin right here.
And Gary was very
specific when he
pulled that out of the ground.
He said that is a
Confederate silver coin.
GARY DRAYTON: It's a coin.
And it's an oldie.
From the Civil War?
GARY DRAYTON: Oh, yeah.
You can see the stars going all
the way around the edges of it.
Wow.
I feel nervous because to look
at Marty the treasure hunter,
I think he wants
to be part of it,
but Marty is not an easy sell.
Hackley.
You got to tie
Hackley in for me.
Hackley becomes this
exceedingly wealthy individual,
claiming that it came from
the lumbering business,
but he never could have
earned the kind of money
that he spent from the
lumbering business.
So it had to come
from somewhere.
Charles Hackley helped
launder this Confederate gold,
so in the archives we
were able to find--
he owned gold mines in Utah.
We found that kind
of interesting.
Gold mines, and of course
smelters with the gold mines
they could melt
down the gold with.
Which is the
very reason we feel
that gold was going across
Lake Michigan out to Utah.
And then we come
across this article.
There was a man out hiking in
the mountains out in Newtown.
He'd come across the
cave, and in the cave
were 280 gold bars
all marked US cavalry.
Did we bring enough?
Did we share enough with
you to jump on board with us
on this project
financially and help
us get a boat to get
to that gold that's
on the bottom of the lake?
MARTY LAGINA: This is
probably your best data.
I can tell you for
sure, without this,
I would for sure
be out because this
is the most hard data you have.
This is necessary
because otherwise
that gold has no business
crossing the lake, right?
But this is going to
be very expensive.
I'm not completely
convinced that this
is enough to go forward.
But I'm going to tell
you, I'm convinced enough.
[laughs] I guess I'm--
I guess I'm on board.
Awesome.
That's more than
what we could ask for.
Yep.
As I was telling Kevin that
I wasn't completely convinced,
I didn't know,
honestly, in my own mind
what the next words
were going to be
till they came out of my mouth.
It was vaguely reminiscent
of Oak Island, though.
I mean, one of the thoughts
in the back of my mind
was this is so familiar.
This is enough to
keep you going.
Let's move forward and
go to the next step.
Let's get your boat.
Let's see what's at the
bottom of Lake Michigan.
Awesome.
Well, Marty, we
can't thank you enough.
I mean, really.
These guys have
worked tirelessly.
They've chased this quest
with me, and this is big.
This is really big.
Now that we have
Marty's support,
I think the whole team is
just as excited as I am.
We made a compelling case that
I verbally said a lot of things.
I think with what
we demonstrated
and what we showed Marty,
we got his support,
and I'm very grateful for that.
OK.
Well, what are we waiting for?
A boat.
[laughter]
Let's get to the
bottom of Lake Michigan.
All righty.